Albrecht von Lucke uns allen sehr wohl
bekannt ich grüße Sie ganz herzlich in
Berlin
guten Tag haben sie einen Tipp wie es
wird nein überhaupt nicht das muss ich
gestehen und man kann nur eines hoffen
man kann nur hoffen und das halte ich
für das entscheidende dass der absurde
proports zwischen Realos und sogenannten
Fundis oder nennen wir es Parteilinken
dass er diesmal nicht wieder zum Tragen
kommt denn eines ist doch die
eigentliche Lehre die die Grüne Partei
aus diesem Jahr eigentlich dramatischen
Ausgang ziehen muss es darf nie wieder
vorkommen dass offensichtlich eine schon
davor in Rheinland-Pfalz heillos
überforderte Familienministerin vor
allem deshalb zu dieser Stellung kommt
weil sie letztlich genau diesen proports
entspricht links Frau und deswegen
geeignet das ist der große Fehler
gewesen und ich glaube es wirft viel
viel mehr Fragen auf ich habe eine
solche eine solche Pressekonferenz wie
die gestrige noch nie erlebt es ist
historisch beispiellos dass ein solches
ich sage vor allem privates Drama das
aber die völlige Untauglichkeit und hart
gesprochen aber vor allem
überfordertheit einer Person gezeigt hat
das sollte alle zum Nachdenken
veranlassen dass diesmal eine bessere
Wahl getroffen wird ja vielleicht auch
die rheinland-pfälzische
Ministerpräsidentin die diese
ehemaligen Ministerin dann noch ein
Ministerium mit hinzugegeben hat nämlich
das Umweltministerium damals wenn
ohnehin schon Holland in Not war auf
deutsch gesagt ja das läuft ja
bekanntlich anders das ist durchaus die
Wahl der dann Betroffenen das waren die
Grünen selbst und hier fängt in der Tat
das Problem an sie sprechen es an wenn
eine Person die schon bereits wie gesagt
der 2019 damals hatte ihr Mann den
Schlaganfall der Mann von Frau Spiegel
wenn in dem Augenblick der Mann sich als
heillos überfordert sieht mit der
Familie immerhin vier Kinder zu Rande zu
kommen die Familienministerin selber
sagt sie ist überfordert sich dann aber
noch die Stärke zutraut ob aus Ehrgeiz
ob aus Druck vielleicht auch anderer
Frauen oder anderer grüner die gesagt
haben das kannst du auch das schaffst du
auch sich dann auch das gewaltig
bedeutende Umweltministerium in
Rheinland-Pfalz zuzuziehen und dann noch
die Taste hat man nie vergessen die
Spitzenkandidatur im Wahlkampf dann ist
hier so etwas die Selbstkontrolle aber
auch eigentliche Einschätzung der Kräfte
aber auch die Einschätzung durch das
Umfeld vollkommen ausgefallen sie
sprechen es zu Recht an das hätte die
Ministerpräsident in V3 ja sehen können
aber viel mehr hätten es noch die
Parteifreunde und Freundin in den grünen
erkennen müssen das ist ein Problem was
ganz grundsätzlicher Natur ist wie sind
Politikerinnen und Politiker in der Lage
noch ein echtes kritisches Umfeld
überhaupt an sich heranzulassen ja und
welche Entscheidungen dann gefällt
werden ich würde mal vorschlagen für
diejenigen die es gestern Abend nicht
gesehen haben verpasst haben wir schauen
uns noch mal einen Ausschnitt aus dem
Pressestatement von Frau Spiegel an
im März 2019 hatte mein Mann einen
Schlaganfall
diese hat dazu geführt dass er seit dem
ganz unbedingt Stress vermeiden musste
die corona-pandemie war für uns mit vier
kleinen Kindern ein Kind im Kita-Alter
und drei Kindern im Grundschulalter
eine wahnsinnige Herausforderung die die
Kinder auch ganz klar
mit Spuren versehen hat
und deshalb
haben wir uns als Familie entschieden
am Sonntag den 25 Juli
in Urlaub zu fahren das war zehn Tage
nach der Flutkatastrophe
und das war ein Fehler dass wir auch so
lange in Urlaub gefahren sind und dass
wir in Urlaub gefahren sind
und ich bitte
für diesen Fehler
um Entschuldigung
ich war
während des Urlaubs immer
erreichbar ich habe Telefonate geführt
und ich habe mich immer informiert und
wenn es irgendeinen Anlass gegeben hätte
den Urlaub abzubrechen dann hätte ich
das auch sofort getan
ich habe nicht aus meinem Urlaub heraus
an den Kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen
aber ich möchte betonen dass ich die
ganze Zeit erreichbar war ich habe mit
Herr Ministerpräsidentin gesprochen ich
habe mit meinen Staatssekretären
gesprochen telefoniert ich habe
natürlich auch war in den Mails
und es ist auch zutreffend dass ich
meinen Urlaub unterbrochen habe um für
einen Tag zurück ins Ahrtal zu kommen
ich
ich möchte mich
für die Fehler
ausdrücklich
entschuldigen
Robert Habeck sagte dazu es sei ihm
unter die Haut gegangen es gibt
verschiedene Kommentierungen von
Beobachtern auch von Journalisten die
Fragen sich relativ laut war das eine
Inszenierung oder zumindest Teil davon
auch eine Frage der Inszenierung was
sagen sie ach das halte ich für völlig
ausgeschlossen ich habe nie eine
Situation
erlebt ich bin jedenfalls keiner solchen
das war ja etwas Dilemma keine
rücktrittsmitteilung man hat ja manche
Politiker völlig erschlagen erlebt
denken wir an Tobias Hans der ist
übrigens noch sehr sehr gut über die
Bühne gebracht hat in der Hinsicht ein
ein vernichtendes Erlebnis ich kann mich
erinnern die erste rücktretende damals
aus dem grünen Kabinett harten Drucks
ausgesetzt Andrea Fischer nach zwei
Jahren das darf man nie vergessen zwei
Jahre nachdem die Koalition begonnen
hatte die erste die damals das rot-grüne
Kabinett
2000 früh im Frühjahr 2001 verlassen
musste das war gestern keine
Inszenierung wir haben ja eine Frau
völlig erschlagen erlebt Worte ringen
muss das kann kein Mensch inszenieren
und es ist natürlich auch zu erklären
dass sie gegen alle Vernunft und das ist
das große Bedauern was ich sage gegen
dich alle Vernunft gestern hätte sie die
Chance gehabt in aller Souveränität zu
sagen und dann hätte es wirklich auch
plausibel erschienen ich habe es nicht
geschafft ich war über meine Grenzen
gegangen sie hat es ja gesagt und ich
ziehe daraus die erforderlichen
Konsequenzen wie ist ihr ja
interessanterweise davor der
Parteivorstand der Grünen inklusive
Fraktionsvorstand bei einer Abstimmung
von 6:0 nahegelegt hat aber nein sie war
in dem Punkt nicht beirrbar sie hat
versucht eine letzte Chance die hat sie
sich Ausbildungen wahrzunehmen und das
war eine Pressekonferenz die historisch
ist ich habe noch nie eine so sprach
ohnmächtige Politikerin erlebt und das
dürfen wir ja nie vergessen wir sind in
einer Zeit da ihr Ministerium mit der
flüchtlingskrise eine der größten Krisen
der Gegenwart zu bewältigen hat und das
ist schon ein ein eine Vorstellung
beziehungsweise eine interessekonferenz
die letztlich die ganze Hilflosigkeit
einer Ministerin kenntlich macht die
davor und das bedauere ich so sehr die
davor hätte einsehen müssen auch hätte
beraten sein müssen dass sie sich mit
all dem überfordert sie hätte schon nach
dem Desaster von Rheinland-Pfalz das ist
übrigens der Vorwurf an die Regierung
von Malu Dreyer in der bisher niemand
niemand außer einem kleinen cdu-landrat
die Verantwortung für die größte
Katastrophe der Nachkriegszeit in
Rheinland-Pfalz übernommen hat sie hätte
schon damals eigentlich der völligen
nichtorganisation in ihres Ministeriums
bei dem sie alles auf den Staatssekretär
abgeschoben hat der übrigens auch in der
Flut versagte sie hätte schon damals
zurücktreten müssen von da aus aber die
noch größeren Sprung in ein
Bundesministerium zu wagen unter all den
Voraussetzungen gestern übrigens noch
deswegen ja diese kleinen laute
Erklärung gestern auch einräumt dass sie
gerade nicht auf die Frage der
Bild-Zeitung die das erfragt hatte wo
sie es wo sie gesagt hätte sie habe an
den Konferenzen im mit dem Kabinett
während der Katastrophe teilgenommen sie
musste auch das als ein Widerspruch hier
stehen das alles hätte dieser Frau zur
Einsicht verhelfen müssen und das macht
das Drama aus gestern wäre sie ihnen
würde abgetreten heute erleben wir eine
historischen Rückzug auf Raten und auch
da ist das letzte Wort was sie ja durch
zitiert haben ausgesprochen fatal sie
ist unter dem politischen Druck
zurückgetreten ja in der Tat der Druck
war so massiv in den heute
beispielsweise Olaf Scholz davon spricht
er war sei bewegt gewesen diese
Politiker ja waren wahrscheinlich
genauso entgeistert als Beobachter wie
ich und es gab doch nur eine Devise der
Schadensbegrenzung halber musste Frau
Spiegel zurücktreten nachdem sie selber
sich gestern final so beschädigt hatte
das war ein Moment der
Schadensbegrenzung der Erleichterung sie
hätte sich das alles leider gestern
Abend ersparen können